from UCLA
thank you for thank you Sanjay for
inviting me to the workshop and it's
great to be here
today I'll tell you about
a classical problem in statistics which
is sparse linear regression and we'll be
talking mostly about what's the
computational efficiency we need for
solving this problem and this is based
on joint work with John Kelner Freddie
coiler uh Andrew
so the problem we're going to study is a
basic regression problem so you have
access to samples from a distribution X
comma y x are your covariance which are
kind of you know maybe the simplest
non-id distribution which is a standard
multivariate gaussian okay so we'll call
x equal variance we have a covariation
you have a covariance matrix Sigma which
can be arbitrary
and the response variable Y is
determined by a spark signal W star so
for each example X you compute its inner
product with your unknown signal W star
and add some noise and that's your
response variable
and that goal is to recover or at least
approximately recover W star depending
on you know how much noise you have and
whether or not even there is noise
because to get small prediction error in
excuse
small prediction error in the right
metric in the sigma metric okay it's a
base simple and basic statistical model
and for Simplicity in the rest of the
talk I'll focus on the case where there
is no noise and we're looking to record
W star exactly our upper ones will
actually generalize to the noises
setting too without much change but let
me focus on this to highlight the main
ideas
so as classical as this problem is there
is still an exponential Gap in what is
possible information theoretically and
for what is possible computational
efficiently so we can show that for any
non-singular Sigma we can actually
recover W star with only K login samples
this applies to Nomad no matter what
Sigma is as long as it's not singular
what do we know in terms of efficient
algorithms for arbitrary Sigma we don't
have anything which runs in less than
Brute Force time meaning you're
enumerating or all possible case bar
signals meaning you can't get runtime
into the little of K with less than
linear or sublinear number of samples
if you have linear number of samples it
just becomes standard linear regression
you don't care about sparsity everything
is fine but once I have some sparsity we
cannot beat or at least we don't know
how to do it with something which is a
little off n
the main challenge is what is the
computational limit at what point can we
get non-brute Force algorithms
there's a lot of work on this problem
especially in the set in the context of
compress sensing and related questions
so one of the most studied techniques
for solving this problem is the L1
minimization method or lasso where you
just try to find a solution consists of
equations x times W equals y but you try
to find a solution which minimizes the
L1 Norm
typically we know that these methods
work if the covariance Matrix for
instance is identity Matrix meaning
everything is independent or the
covariance Matrix is well conditioned
meaning typical guarantees again you
know this is all in courts because there
are lots of different versions you know
different optimizations but typically
it's something like this if the
condition number of a matrix Sigma is
capital T then you get some sample
complexity which is K times T Times log
n and your runtime is going to be very
efficient polynomial time for sure and
even better in some cases
but the dependence on T is what is not
there in the information theoretic bound
and that's what we're focusing on and
what do you know in terms of
computational barriers we know that this
regression problem is hard in the worst
case meaning if I give you a fixed set
of samples you know X1 through XM it's a
fixed Matrix then there are hard
instances you can embed pretty much set
cover or independent set without too
much difficulty
and for specific algorithms such as
lasso we do know that there are
covariances which make loss of fail
there are some Sigma where Lassa would
not work with K log and Sample
complexity
but even though it makes lasso fail if
you just do a simple basis chain it
starts working again
that's something we're going to talk
about in a little bit in the worst case
hardness result depending is the simple
capacity depends like linearly on the
condition number or uh like could you go
for root t or something or
very strong lower volume and basically
says that as long as you have a 10 over
10 samples you're going to really need
exponent almost exponential number
exponential contact
assuming some other hardness basically
you can register from something like
leak okay precise dependence on
condition number is not clear
yeah maybe root B I would say I'm saying
like basically it's hard to decipher
what the dependence on T would be from
their construction because T kind of
appears both in terms of the number of
variables and
so it's not immediate it
kind of relates to this question how are
these matrices like what is how what is
Sigma for those matrices that make last
but there is no Stigma there it's just a
fixed Matrix meaning you know I have x
one through x n so your it's a fixed
design memory okay so it's not really
you have you don't have a distribution
but which we know it is hard when you
can mix you can say it's a distribution
with finite Supply sure but that's about
the element and how do they make this my
disease so you take an instance of set
cover that is an example and like in a
recessive correspond to the rows and you
have to do some maybe a couple of clicks
on top but that's something like that
the first sort of thing significant we
can then different variations give you
nice trade-offs
all right so the main questions then
where can you bridge this exponential
Gap and you can work on trying to bridge
it from both ends right so on one end
you can ask
uh can I find can I go beyond worst case
we know we don't have many strong very
strong algorithms for worst case
instances of Sigma now just a covariance
matrix are they interesting special
classes of covariances where we can get
efficient algorithms
and wealth condition we know is enough
for actually designing algorithms but
it's somehow
doesn't capture many other interesting
regression problems
as we'll see they're natural instances
where the condition number is terrible
and in fact these methods will fail
and on the other hand you can ask okay
are there class of algorithms that we
know will fail for this random instances
meaning there's a fixed Sigma but it's
an average gets lower bound because the
input your algorithm is randomized
can we get worse maybe can you show this
is hard for some class of algorithms as
we'll see later but again when you say
worst case hardness not enough you mean
worst case hardness the fixed design
setting yeah in the fixed design setting
so but that's
oh I see that's a totally different
thing like there you're assuming you're
not assuming gaussianity yeah yeah
exactly so that's the only hardness we
know so it's much poor you know you're
right actually says there's two
different words
in your talk today everything is
gaussian today yeah
everything is over everything is over
there's an exponential gap for them
okay and we'll see an example of you
know making progress on the Beyond risk
setting we look at various covalences
which are ill-conditioned but if they
have some specific graphical structure
I'll Define what it is then you can
solve it in almost uh optimal sample
complexity again definitely the
dependence on N is going to be
logarithmic or poly logarithmic
and the main Technique we use for
solving this which is pre-conditioning
the lasso method whichever has
limitations even though it works for
this graphical structure
you can show that there are
covariance matrices which cannot be
preconditioned so that lasso would work
okay even if you know the sigma you
cannot design a preconditioner even
based on Signal
but I'll get more precise as we go along
okay so first let me talk about the
upper bar which is how do I precondition
uh to solve some ill-conditioned SLR
instances and I'll use this random walk
as a motivating example they both
describe the problem and also describe
the algorithm and then we'll generalize
it without too much difficulty
so what's the random walk covariance
Matrix so here you should think of RS as
X I just for the random walk setting
so you have n random variables as before
they're all gaussian but they're being
generated as follows I have IID gaussian
G1 through ZN which are kind of late n
and each the ith variable that you
actually see as covariate is your I
minus 1 variable plus this independent
gaussian ZR
okay
so each the variable is just the sum of
the prefix of disease up to I
The covariance Matrix of this is exactly
you know if you just spend situated
little the correlations are exactly this
so the covariance Matrix is very simple
and nice
has kind of almost the same nice pattern
but if you focus on the diagonal you can
see that the ratio of the entries
or the Matrix Matrix
changes or increases with the dimension
okay so this covariance Matrix is
actually very badly conditional it's ill
condition the condition number depends
on the dimension n
and this is kind of where you can think
maybe not this exact equation but this
sort of dependency structure is can can
arise in the real world for example if
you have time series data where your
next variable only depends on the
previous one or maybe a few before that
then you might get such a setting okay
and as I said it's ill-conditioned and
so I'll get the guarantees that we know
longer apply
all right
and it's not just that they no longer
apply an analysis they actually fail
when you implement them
so if you take lasso or BP or any other
methods
on a case where the net the the
dimension is large like 32 000 but the
sparsity is two
okay so it should be something like 2
log n information theoretically but
you see that you know the existing
methods need a lot of samples to work
particularly it seems to be almost
linear in n
but there is one outlier here the black
curve which is going to be a
precondition method uh which solves this
problem even with the almost the right
sample context
okay because if Case constant I can do
polynomial time right it depends like it
doesn't say like if K is 100 and to the
100 runtime is not good for me all right
so you don't want to think K is
constants yeah or you can say okay one k
is like 1000 but I want my runtime to be
like N squared and we shouldn't the
exponent should not depend okay
right but it's best to think of gay as
being like logarithmic or something
non-constant and then makes a lot of
sense
so the technique that we're going to
study is preconditioning so
preconditioning something that gets
widely used in numerical in your algebra
and solving linear systems and also in
many other optimization
algorithms and here we're going to try
and use it for improving the sample
complexity not for kind of the runtime
but for the sample complexity so what is
precondition Basis pursuit or
precondition lasso
instead of you're still looking to solve
x times W equals y but instead of
minimizing the L1 Norm of w by itself
you try to minimize the album after some
basis change
the if s this made the preconditioning
Matrix is invertible this essentially
corresponds to making the transformation
s inverse X now you have your original X
you make it X inverse X and then you're
running lasso
okay both are equivalent
so if you are trying to use
preconditioning the idea is you know
maybe your original uh set of random
variables X1 through x n their condition
number is bad I'm going to do a basis
change to make the condition number very
good and then I'll use lasso that's the
simple thing to try simplest thing to
probably try and let's try and do this
for random variables R1 through RN for
the random walk right so you want to
transform them into Wis w13wn
maybe the first thing you would try is
because I want good condition number
right somehow I want independence
the first thing to try is to take the
differences
25 and new variables wi as RM minus RN
minus 1 then I'm golden because we know
that the differences are all independent
standard gaussians
so the good here is that we got the
covariance to be perfect it's identity
so it's extremely well conditioned okay
so if you were to you could have used
the lasso guarantees from earlier
but the problem the ugly part is that we
lost the sparsity of the signal
what do I mean suppose the response
variable y was just r 1000
. so it's a one sparse linear
combination of your input covariates R1
through RN right but under this basis
change in the new basis the response
variable becomes the sum of the first
thousand variables
okay so you lost sparsity so the lasso
guarantees do not apply
right so the simple thing first thing to
try it doesn't work mainly because we
want this transformation to not only
make the condition number better but
also to go back with sparse combination
meaning we want each RI to also be a
sparse combination of our new variables
WI
we have these two then this would work
basically you improve the condition
number you don't blow up the sparsity
too much
so that's our revised goal we have a
better understanding of why it's
necessary and a trick to do that is a
simple geometric one the idea is to
exploit the nice markovian structure of
the random walk
so what do I mean if I take the middle
vertex the RT over 2th variable
then
everything to the left of it the first
you know uh half minus one variables
become independent of the right half
myosin radicals once a condition on the
middle one the left and right become
independent more generally if a
condition on the ith variable the left
and right P says RI plus 1 through RN as
a set become independent of R1 to RM and
so on
okay Independence is good because
condition even the condition variables
will be gaussian random variables and if
they're independent then their inner
product is zero so the covariance
becomes very nice
okay
so the idea is to do this recursively so
let's say I have seven variables you
know this X size
I take the middle vertex X4 and
condition it out meaning I'm replacing
each of the other ones in some kind of
uh by shift of X4 so that the inner
products become zero
okay
by each one I must subtract the right
multiple of X4
that splits out the left and right
halves they become independent and now
you're recur so you have two separate
problems so you do it again
you have to do a little bit of
arithmetic to figure out these
combinations but you know once you know
this once you have this idea you can
work it out without too much difficulty
and if you do this for this special case
of seven variables this is the picture
you get
and by the marker property you can argue
that all of these variables the new
variables that you have here you just
did a linear transformation of your
original inputs they're all independent
of each other
you can check by just taking the inner
products they'll exactly cancel out and
give you Independence
okay so we got Nice condition number now
the other thing to check is are we
preserving sparsity
what do you think
this Varsity is also fine because it
depends on the depth of it
so because you can write each of the old
variables as something along this path
as a path in this binary tree so you can
do it with exactly login loss in
sparsity
so every old variable is the sum of log
and new variables for instance X1 you
can write it as basically trace the path
along to the leaf corresponding to X1
right
so that's our desired basis change we
kind of got to this in this uh intuitive
way yeah so I don't understand the
construction can you explain
what is independent so basically imagine
so there is a way to come up with this
right this coefficients okay based on
this recursion idea but suppose I have
this original variables X1 through X7
now I did a transformation where I'm
replacing X1 with like X1 minus half X2
and you know all of this other stuff so
this is a linear transformation of this
and the point now is that each of these
new variables they're all independent of
each other
so I have a new nvariate distribution
like all seven choose two or independent
yeah exactly because it's gaussian you
know once the inner product becomes zero
they become independent
okay
I mean it relies on charity the
independence you can still ensure by
markovian property but gaussianity
really comes from the fact that the
conditional distributions are linear
shifts
reasonably strongly so if I have a
covariometric Boost distribution is
subgaussian at this
it might not be might not work with this
simple idea but at least maybe there's
some variant of the splitting of the
graph right actually work in some sense
so like the yeah like the markup
property may not like in gaussian the
best predictor of one thing everything
else within years
models that's why yeah gaussian is
important which is what we're saying but
on their hand if you just have the
covariance Matrix and inverted and this
Matrix
is this graphical structure there's kind
of like Independence that only look at
linear functions and it works actually
under much weaker distribution so for
blockchain distributions it's easy to
understand what the dependency graphics
for sub gaussians it's not like if I
just tell you the covariance you don't
know what the dependency graph is
so if you know that the dependency graph
is of this form
then and some conditions you can do it
even for some some gaussian or even some
exponential distributions
it depends on the dependency
I don't see Independence X1 minus half x
two and then X7 minus X6 suppose I take
these two n leaves but then when they
multiply them I don't see any terms
canceling so what do you mean by
Independence well okay I'm missing
something capture uh failure they've
been this calculation right but if you
take the inner product maybe you can
check right you know what's in compared
to one and seven it's one one and six is
one so it gets canceled right and half
of X2 is uh inner product X7 is two you
get two minus two you get zero okay okay
because you're getting cancellation okay
now I get it thanks but you can check
manually but the way you're doing it
really is one step at a time so you
enter again at the left half and the
right half you're satisfied it once and
then inductive will satisfy it again
yeah I mean if you check like basically
the correlation of X1 with X7 and x x
direction is the same so when you take
the difference it goes
yeah
so x i is your Design Within your
regression yeah
yeah yeah right because this particular
design exactly exactly
[Music]
so this actually this basis change is uh
also has a name in history it's actually
the hardware basis okay so you can also
just say okay we're doing the hardware
like business but thinking about this
way will help us generalize a bit more
as we'll see okay
as a corollary you know you basically
get that when the covariance Matrix is
from the random walk so let's say you
have you're trying to do regression on
time series data the coefficient as I
said they're not important what's
important is markup property
then precondition BP you can solve that
problem with basically K log squared and
samples
and random walk is kind of in our
argument itself you can see that you're
not really using too much about the
coefficients of the work so there's a
more General thing that we can extract
yeah you because of the transformation
your spasticity got the login Factor
that's why there's a lock screen exactly
so what is the preconditioning here so
the first preconditioning you had was
simply Sigma inverse and that is
right with this construction what is the
preconditioning so the preconditioning
is uh basically whatever transformation
we are doing
right so you're kind of describing s
inverse in some sense
you do this transformation and then
you're solving L1 just in this space
just make sure also you need to control
the coefficients you need to control the
coefficients that the coefficients will
not be too big either
so in general going beyond the random
work how is this preconditional going to
look yeah I'll tell you that in a second
so to abstract it out let's first look
at the main property of random work that
we're using which is the mark following
marker property so for any graph for any
uh
set of variables X1 to X N you can
define independency graph
if we say G is a dependency path if
whenever you have two vertices
that are not adjacent in this graph
then they are independent condition on
neighbors of one vertex
so meaning so for instance for example
for random walk it corresponds to the
path being a dependency graph because if
I take any two variables then
conditioning on neighbors of one vertex
meaning I'm conditioning on let's say at
least one next to it then the two
variables become independent
okay so more generally you're saying I
know I might have an arbitrary graph not
necessarily a path
you could have a grid graph you could
have all kinds of graphs that show up
and for gaussian distributions it's a
this is a nice way to get to dependency
graphs and that comes in the Precision
Matrix so it is well known from I think
the 70s that if I take covariance Matrix
and look at its inverse the Precision
matrix it's non-zero entries tell you
exactly the dependency graph of the
distribution
okay
and this dependency graph you know this
class of models are also called gaussian
graphical models and learning them and
using them uh has been studied a lot on
its own
but today we're just going to use them
for
uh as an assumption so that we can solve
sparse linear regression okay
all right
so we're going to assume that the
dependency graph of the distribution has
small T width five minutes
right and
so why is tree width a nice concept if
you don't know what preview it is the
main thing to keep in mind is the
following property of tree width you see
Satish has walked in exactly when I'm
talking about
[Laughter]
somewhere the bells rang
ers
so you have some balance separated here
so this is the main property of the
dependency graph that we're going to use
that is the tree with the speed then you
can partition the graph into two smaller
pieces by taking out only a small number
of vertices so the tree width is T their
constant times T many vertices that you
can find such that if I cut them if I
remove them from the graphs and the
graph partitions into two pieces where
no piece is bigger than two thirds so
you're getting a constant fraction drop
by only removing a constant number
depending on T many vertices
so now we have this what should I do to
get my preconditioner
in sessions
well you do the same recursive thing
right you kind of take out the vertices
in the middle you know let's call the
set at a so you identify the vertices in
a you orthogonalize everything else with
respect to these variables again I'm
saying orthogonalized because basically
just like doing some kind of branch make
process with these vectors to begin with
some simple algebra there and then you
recurse on the left and right pieces
the intuition is the same these set of
variables and this set of variables are
not completely independent of each other
so what do you do there what you do here
doesn't affect the covariance Matrix in
the end
and because the sizes of this left and
right pieces is always dropping by at
least a constant Factor your process
will stop within login depth
and in each step you're taking out P
vertices so the size of this cut in the
end you're trying to increase you'll
increase the sporosity by something like
T Times log n
uh so we need to know the graph for sure
I'll talk about that in a second and I
mean I don't know the best one but we're
just not uh we're assuming it's kind of
known in some instance
actually that's a good point we don't
need to find like you know we only need
an approximation
like a constant Factor approximation is
good enough for us because all we need
is this geometric decay
is also easy to find separator and so on
foreign
techniques I have a long history
numerical in your algebra this has some
this is very close to something called
nested dissection techniques for solving
linear systems which was done way back
in the 70s
so in summary what you get is that if
the dependency graph has three with t
then you can solve it and precondition
belief propagation or basis pursuit or
any of these things
once you do the basis change we'll solve
sparse in regression and the number of
samples is going to be K times T Times
log squared okay so for constant
previous you're doing really well and
concentrate with models are relatively
common they can it can be arise for
instance in linear dynamical systems
Auto regressive models where let's say
you have time series data for example
and you say okay the next variable only
depends on my past 10 events and then
there's some randomness
these are also called structural causal
models so you're in all of those things
you might get something like this
so let me now in the remaining two
minutes so I'll tell you tell you a
statement of our lower bound
so we saw that if the dependency gave a
small private then we can do it with
without assuming anything to do with the
condition number and actually I should
say that we don't need to know the
covariance Matrix for upper bar
we need to only know the dependency
graph okay sometimes the dependency
graph is something that you can you know
from prior knowledge maybe the exact
coefficients that you have it might be a
heartfelong to learn
but what about other dependence
instructors suppose you have uh
variables which are kind of being
generated on a grid
right so grid it has this annoying
property that it is uh tree width is
very large
okay so what do you do in this case our
method as I stated doesn't work the grid
graph the dependency graph is very
sparse seems very nice but the tree with
this Omega root type
okay and what we show is that
unfortunately there's some kind of uh
tree width is a bottleneck high traffic
is a bottleneck for preconditioning as a
whole
meaning for any graph which has three
with the T there is some covariance
Matrix that you can put whose dependency
graph is exactly that graph
and
any preconditioning that you can think
of it can depend on the graph it can
depend on Sigma
would still require t to the 1 over 20
samples
so the emphasis is basically on the fact
that the preconditioning can depend on
Sigma or anything but still you'll get
this lower bound
and if you don't I mean even if you
don't focus on tree with this
independently interesting basically
you're saying that there are covariance
matrices Sigma for which even if the
sparse signal has parsity like log n
any preconditioned lasso will require
polynomial number of samples
10 to the Omega 1.
and this is first such lower Bound for a
broad class of algorithms brought here
corresponds to any possible
preconditional you can use
okay
and preconditioning means made only make
only linear Transformations only linear
transformation yeah but you know the
transformation can depend on
your Sigma
but there could be some other
transformation or there could be another
context program yeah
so after doing the transformation you
could ask you know maybe instead of L1
Norm I do something else but although
you know I think you might be able to
handle that but the main thing is a
linear transformation
so the high level proof sketch is uh you
know interest of time I won't say what
it is but basically it involves some
gadgets and it's more complicated part
of the paper it takes a lot of effort to
kind of get it on a grid
and let me finish with uh basically what
are the next steps possible
first we don't know how I mean our thing
fails when you have high trivet and it's
a there's a good reason it fails that
preconditioning as a whole won't work
and you can ask what happens you know
maybe
um can I do it on grid graph or what if
the distribution has some kind of sparse
factorization The covariance Matrix as
far as factorization and more generally
I like this theme of using structural
assumptions on your covariance Matrix
especially on like let's say by markup
property or something nice about the
dependency graph to go beyond worst case
I think that's something that could be
useful for other regression problems as
well
let me end with that
foreign
so you mentioned that you don't need to
know Sigma you only need to know the
graphical structure but then in The
Graduate process you had that x i x j
yeah
because you know the sparsity is small
enough that you don't need to do it
fully it requires a bit of care to kind
of make sure the errors are not going up
and so on right you can do it
thank you very much
to see the procedure outward so usually
we want slots so to make this on future
selections
but here you are using Smart City in a
different space right so basically it
might be true that your signal is parsed
in a different space can you somehow
automatically find it so you understand
Solutions sparse and original space
that's about somewhere else so we cannot
do any more features
um I think the map list or like at least
the one we use for the algorithms
foreign
so you have your original set of
variables so you think it's first
lecture you multiply by matrix what is
the instructions it's a double linear
combinations of x i but with x i by not
sparse right but just so much resistance
uh it gets Varsity here so the new
variables wi that you have are sparse
combinations of the old ones
yeah
thank you very much